depuis 66 ans la maison familial lener
cordier est expert du manteau et du
trench avec la crise du coronavirus ses
activités traditionnelles se sont
complètement arrêté mais son président a
une idée pour apporter sa pierre à
l'édifice produire des masques avec
l'aide des salariés ce sont entre 3000
et 4000 masque qui sont ainsi produits
chaque jour on a gardé un service
minimum et notre production française a
été totalement arrêtée et puis quelques
jours après on s'est mobilisé pour la
production de masse qu'on avait là
matière première pour le faire
notre personnel est venu mais d'une
façon la fleur au fusil j'allais dire
l'expression ne fait pas choisi lens
moment mais en tout cas d'une façon très
très enthousiaste et très vite en a
mobilisé l'ensemble de ce personnel en
produit des masques tous les jours à
raison de 3000 3500 masque jour des
masques mais aussi des blouses jetables
pour le personnel soignant une demande
formulée par l'hôpital d'hazebrouck pour
lutter contre les problèmes de pénurie
cette fois ce ne sont pas des salariés
de l'entreprise mais des couturières
bénévoles qui sont appelés en renfort
c'est lener cordier qui coupent toute
toute la partie textile
on a tissé christophe le bac me les
dépose chez moi et moi je redis ce patch
avec mes couturière du secteur combien
couturière vous devez trouver sur deux
secteurs alors là j'en suis à peu près à
il n'ya plus de stocks nulle part et
comme les trois quarts sont fabriqués à
l'étranger
le problème
et la haye
c'est bien de retrouver des petites
structures comme ça au niveau local pour
pouvoir avancer et pour pouvoir protéger
les soignants auprès des malades des
solutions locales mais aussi économique
alors que la production de blues est
évalué à 8 euros pièce en atelier celle
de la maison lener cordier ne coûtent 95
centimes d'euro